hello my name is Hakeem doberman I'm the
deputy director-general for research of
the international rice research
institute or URI and the gentlemen
besides me here is Lee while is the head
of our experimental station and what we
want to do with you in the next few
months is actually learn how to grow a
crop of rice
not just any crop of rice we want to do
it in the best possible manner we can
think of now we are scientists so we do
a lot of research we believe that we
know a lot about rice and how to grow it
in different part of the world and we
have lots of recommendations for farmers
and extension workers we often call them
best management practices you can find
them on the internet and all rights
knowledge bank in extension but there's
in books and scientific papers but what
we really really want to do is try to
practice what we preach because often we
scientists may come up with things that
you know don't really work in practice
or sometimes you wonder why aren't
people using them so that's why Lee and
I have decided well why don't we do it
ourselves as much as we can do ourselves
because some of the things we may not be
really qualified to do but we'll try
okay we will we will be qualified not
only what qualifies you to grow the
scope of rice yes well I'm something of
a fraud myself I am a rice farmer in
Australia but juda dry conditions and an
absence from Australia for the last
three years I have a stood my rice crop
last rice crop six years ago six years
ago now I'm a little rusty as well and
you have not really done this in a
setting like this one here in the humid
tropics with small field and wet
environment exactly right I'm out of my
comfort zone I suspect you're out of
your comfort zone so that's a good place
well I've done research on this for 20
years but really you know have
I have already done all these things
together in a larger field probably not
you know I have other people or had
other people to do it for me
but you know that's probably not the
right thing to do so come and join us
come back with us pretty much every week
in the coming months and learn with us
what what we do will also not be shy at
all to show you what we might screw up
I'm sure we're going to mess up a few
things you know but that's it we want to
learn and we want to make sure that the
things that we recommend the farmers
coming out of our research actually work
so we'll see where we are four months
from now in terms of what crop we have
grown what its yield has been we are we
are setting a high yield target
we're not embarrassed to say that yeah
what's the target well normally we would
say with best management practices you
would like to shoot for a yield of about
80% of yield potential new potential
here is for any good dry season it's
between nine and ten tonnes nowadays so
our goal should be probably let's say a
seventh on crop that sounds whether we
achieve it we don't know but we'll be no
more than four months from now
thank you